how do you advise people that are
dealing with imposter syndrome
oh everyone deals with that
every time you make a status shift as
you move upwards of course you have
imposter syndrome because when you first
make a transition into a new role you
are an imposter because you're a
beginner you don't know what you're
doing
and that doesn't mean you're a liar or a
fake and it doesn't mean you should
presume more knowledge than you have
it's what did nietzsche say every great
man is an actor of his own ideal
and that's
that's that's that feeds into the
imposter syndrome in some sense if you
want to move to the next stage at some
point you have to act like you're
already there when you're just barely
started
and that's not a lie
you know it's it's the willingness it
can be and it can degenerate into a lie
especially if you presume more than you
know
but
if you move you know let's say you move
from being an undergraduate to a
graduate student
well every all the other graduate
students and the professors know that
you're just a beginning graduate student
they're they're not going to expect as
much from you as they would from a more
seasoned graduate student
so you have some leeway that's genuine
but you are you know the low-rung
occupier of that role and of course
you're gonna feel like you're an
imposter
if you have any sense because you're
just barely there you you just made the
transition that's okay you know that's
not a problem you first of all you have
to understand that
everyone with any sense who isn't
narcissistic feels that and it's
actually an indication of your mental
health and your competence as long as
that doesn't become crippling it
shouldn't knock you out i'm such a phony
well don't be a phony that's the first
thing
if you're dealing with competent people
and you admit your ignorance the
competent people never judge you harshly
for that
as long as you've been paying attention
so in my classes for example people were
often afraid to ask questions and so
sometimes i would point to people and
ask them if they had a question
especially the quieter types
and they'd be afraid to ask the question
because they're revealing their
ignorance and they would assume they're
the only person in the room that's that
ignorant but they're not because if they
were paying attention and they had a
question the probability that half the
class had that question was really high
that's different if you're not paying
attention and so you can be
ignorant you can be an ignorant newbie
and you can even ask the questions that
are necessary to ask in that position
and sort of reveal your inadequacy and
as long as you're dealing with competent
people
and you've been paying attention they're
they're just going to answer your
questions and then you only have to be
ignorant once
that's the thing about asking
a stupid question
you only have to ask it once then you're
no longer stupid to well balanced people
that intellectual humbleness is
endearing right really endearing yes so
one of the things that i want just
because they're always asking questions
too they always have impostor syndrome
too
if they have any sense like
what do you what are you more what you
know or what you don't know
well if you're competent you know you're
more what you don't know and so you're
always asking questions you see someone
else asking questions you think oh
you're asking questions you probably are
competent
so and there's the trajectory that's the
trajectory of a person that will become
competent or more comfortable in the
future too right so
what i would hope with imposter syndrome
and this is something that i noticed
first off in myself but then in other
people as well
um
i've bro scienced my way into something
called imposter adaptation
so
hedonic adaptation is the
phenomenon where your happiness level
tends to reset after a change in
circumstances so you buy a new car or
get a new house or get the job promotion
and it feels good for a while but then
it resets imposter syndrome being that
you never feel fully worthy of any
achievements that you get in your life
and you don't feel like you are worthy
of being there imposter adaptation is a
real nefarious version of this where no
matter how many times you disprove your
lack of self belief it continues to
persist in the real world and this there
is a kernel of truth in this because
what you said if you're trailblazing if
you haven't done this thing before
but you also have to think well how many
times have i done something analogous to
this how many times have i done
something that's kind of like this but
not not quite yet well people who are
high in trait neuroticism are more
likely to feel that way
because
so
neuroticism is the negative emotion per
personality trait and it's a index of
sensitivity to
threat and punishment essentially
so imagine that it's very difficult to
calibrate how many units of
physiological preparedness you should
manifest per unit of threat
right because how big is the threat the
answer is
you don't know
you wake up in the morning and
you have an ache in your side
is that nothing
or is that the cancer that's going to
kill you in six months
and it's pretty low probability that
it's the latter but the probability is
not zero so why shouldn't you be
panicked out of your mind and the answer
is some people are
and sometimes they're right
so the calibration of threat especially
when it's associated with novelty is
virtu
an impossibly difficult computational
problem we have like 10 different
mechanisms to try to solve that and one
of the mechanisms is well there's
tremendous variability in response and
if you're higher in trait neuroticism
you're going to have the problem you're
described all the time you're going to
be doubtful about your
competence and the validity of your
position
and
the only treatment we really know for
that is to expose yourself to things
that you're afraid of voluntarily and
to become braver as a consequence of
doing that but some people have to live
with that more than other people
the thing that i realized was that
after a while if you continue to
disprove your imposter syndrome in the
real world yeah
you have a challenge you're adamant that
you probably won't or might not or don't
deserve to get past it and then you do
after a while you have to admit to
yourself that your imposter syndrome has
nothing to do with your capacity and
everything to do with your addiction
about feeling like an imposter yeah and
well and that that does change as people
age
generally speaking they become
more agreeable more conscientious and
lower in negative emotion and some of
that is that adaptation you see that
you've
survived through various challenges
and then you can review that evidence to
yourself but also the people around you
bolster you
because they have confidence in you and
so their anxiety doesn't trigger your
anxiety and they'll remind you too
you know you've got this you've done
things in the such a wealth of data you
know you've done it so many times yeah
and yeah i think and that and that does
help i mean it does help people get more
confident as they get older and they
accrue experience because of that but
it's subject to that
underlying
trait variability and sensitivity to
negative emotion i mean there there's
been good psychometric analysis of
self-esteem scales
and neuroticism scales
and they're that pretty much the same
thing
reversed
and so
are you confident in yourself
self-esteem do you lack confidence trait
neuroticism and so it is harder for some
people because it takes more evidence
for them to dampen down their their
response to threat
so and and it's partly because
we're all adapted to some degree to the
failure of induction right just because
something happened multiple times in the
past does not mean
necessary that it will happen the next
time and that's a big bro it's the
farmer and chicken problem right
farmer's always feeding the chicken
chicken thinks the farmer's his best
friend but one day the chicken is dinner
and that's induction
there was a stable pattern in the past
you come to rely on it but at any time
that axiom can be disproved
and so
the fact that we have
variability and trait neuroticism is a
consequence of
the the the probability of the failure
of induction
it's it's a very difficult problem to
solve how to regulate negative emotion
you know
and
but i would say that the best way we
know is to keep
facing challenges voluntarily pay
attention
at a rate that works for you
develop your competence that actually
stabilizes the environment around you so
it's it actually is less predictable and
less threatening plus you accrue that
evidence and you get the social support
for doing so that's your best pathway
forward what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you